franz kafka was a great czech
writer who has come to own a part of the
human emotional spectrum
which we can now call the kafka-esque
and which thanks to him
were able better to recognize and to
gain a measure of perspective over
and relief from kafka's world isn't
pleasant
it feels in many ways like a nightmare
and yet it's a place where many of us
will
even if only for a time in the dark
periods of our lives end up
we're in the world defined by kafka when
we feel powerless in front of authority
judges aristocrats industrialists
politicians
and most of all fathers when we feel
that our destiny is out of our control
when we're bullied humiliated and mocked
by society
and especially by our own families we're
in kafka's orbit when we're ashamed of
our bodies
of our sexual urges and feel that the
best thing for us
might be to be killed or squashed
without mercy
as if we were an inconvenient and rather
disgusting bed bug
franz kafka was born in prague in 1883
the eldest child of a terrifyingly
psychologically abusive father
and a mother who was too weak and in awe
of her husband to protect her boy
as she should have done kafka grew up
timid
bookish meek and full of self-hatred
he wanted to become a writer but it was
out of the question in his father's eyes
so one of the greatest german literary
geniuses since goethe
was forced to spend his brief life on
earth working in a series of jobs
utterly beneath him
in a law office and then an insurance
company
he had a number of unsuccessful
relationships with women he couldn't
marry or raise a family
and was tormented by the strength of his
sex drive which made him constantly turn
to brothels and pornography
kafka published very little in his
lifetime just three collections of short
stories
including his best known work the
metamorphosis and he was entirely
obscure and unnoticed
his gigantic posthumous reputation is
based on three novels
the trial the castle and america which
were all unfinished because kafka was so
dissatisfied with them
he gave orders that they be destroyed
after his death
fortunately for humanity these were
disobeyed
it shouldn't sound prurient or reductive
to suggest that one of the major keys to
understanding kafka
is to fathom the nature of his
relationship with his father
kafka never wrote directly about this
man in any of his works
but the psychology of the novels is
directly related to the dynamics he
endured
as the very unfortunate son of hermann
kafka
any boy who has ever felt inadequate in
front of or unloved by a powerful
father will at once relate to what kafka
went through in his childhood
in november 1919 at the age of 36
five years before his death kafka wrote
a 47-page letter to hermann
in which he tried to explain how his
childhood had deformed him
like many victims of abuse kafka never
stopped hoping for some kind of
forgiveness
from the person who had so wronged him
dearest father went the letter
you asked me recently why i maintain
that i'm so afraid of you
as usual i was unable to think of any
answer to your question
partly for the very reason that i am
afraid of you
and partly because an explanation of the
grounds for this fear
would mean going into far more details
than i could ever keep in mind while
talking
the grown kafka abased himself before
this father
what i would have needed was a little
encouragement a little friendliness
but i wasn't fit for that what was
always incomprehensible to me
was your total lack of feeling for the
suffering and shame you could inflict on
me
with your words and judgments it was as
though you had no notion of your power
kafka complained of one particularly
traumatic incident
when as a young boy he called out for a
glass of water
and his irritable father pulled the boy
out of his bed carried him out onto the
balcony and left him there to freeze in
nothing but his night shirt
kafka writes i was quite obedient after
that period
but it did me so much incalculable inner
harm
even years afterwards i suffered from
the tormenting fancy that the huge man
my father
the ultimate authority would come almost
for no reason at all
and take me out of bed in the night and
carry me out onto the balcony
and that meant i was a mere nothing for
him
boys need their father's permission to
become men
and herman kafka didn't give france a
chance
at a very early stage you forbade me to
speak your threat not a word of
contradiction
and the raised hand that accompanied it
have been with me ever since
france's sense of inadequacy was total
i was weighed down by your mere physical
presence i remember for instance
how often we undressed in the same
bathing hut there was eyes
skinny weakly slight you strong tall
broad i felt a miserable specimen when
we stepped out
you holding me by my hand a little
skeleton unsteady
frightened of the water incapable of
copying your swimming strokes
i was frantic with desperation it could
hardly have been worse
except it was kafka finished the letter
gave it to his mother julie to pass to
hermann
but typical of her weakness and
cowardice she didn't
she held on to it for a few days then
returned it to france
and advised that it would be better if
her busy hard-working husband
never had to read such a thing the poor
son
lacked the courage ever to try again in
the judgment kafka's great short story
written in 1912 a young businessman
georg
is engaged to be married and lives in a
flat with his widowed father
he's about to get away from home the
father is old and frail
georg tucks him up in bed but then the
father mysteriously regains his strength
springs upright towers over georg and
denounces him for betraying everyone
his friends his father and the memory of
his mother
georg can make only feeble protests
eventually the father condemns george to
death by drowning
and georg obediently rushes out and
plunges into the nearby river
after passing sentence the father cries
out you were an innocent
child really but at heart you were a
diabolical human being
the idea of horrific arbitrary judgment
was to be a constant in kafka's fiction
it reappears in the unfinished novel the
trial written two years later
but now kafka had developed it away from
a father to a vast
legal apparatus with judges lawyers
guards
and extensive bureaucratic procedures
when joseph k
is arrested on the morning of his 30th
birthday he isn't told what he is
charged with
he barely makes any attempt to find out
he feels so guilty inside
he just knows that he deserves
punishment he does try to declare in
court
that he's innocent still without knowing
what the charge is
and hires a lawyer but the court
gradually grinds him down
he becomes unable to think of anything
words fail him
he can no longer do his job properly and
is defeated in the game of office
politics
finally a year after his arrest two
grotesque looking officials
come to joseph k's flat they lead him to
a quarry outside the city
and execute him by plunging a knife into
his heart
between the judgment and the trial kafka
wrote the metamorphosis
a short story in which a travelling
salesman gregor samsa
wakes up one morning transformed into an
insect akin to a beetle or a bed bug
it's a story of self-disgust about the
treachery of family
and like the trial about terrifying
arbitrary power
when gregor crawls across the floor he
is in danger of being stamped on by his
own father
gregor's family find they manage quite
well without him they can
find him to his room and chuck rubbish
at him the family hold a council
and decide that the insect in the
bedroom can't really be gregor
they start to refer to the insect as it
instead of him
they decide that somehow the insect has
to go gregor
listening agrees and dies quietly
after gregor's death the family are
slightly ashamed of their behavior
but only slightly kafka suffered from
ill health for a lot of his life
in 1924 when he was 41 he developed
laryngeal tuberculosis
which prevented him from eating almost
anything without huge pain
he wrote a short story his last called
the hunger artist
it tells the story of a public performer
who makes his living
undertaking fasts for the pleasure of
the public
one time he manages to fast for forty
days
but gradually the hunger artist's
audience gets bored of his work
however hard he fasts they're no longer
impressed
he gets put in a dirty old cage and
weakens terribly
before he dies he asks for forgiveness
and confesses that he should never have
been admired
since the reason he fasted was simply
that he couldn't find any food he
enjoyed
shortly after he dies he's replaced in
his cage by a panther
an animal full of vigor whom the crowd
love and who has a voracious appetite
a few days after finishing the hunger
artists kafka died
and was buried in the jewish cemetery in
prague within a few years of his death
his reputation began by the second world
war
he was recognized as one of the greatest
writers of the age
notwithstanding all his close family
were gassed by the germans in the
holocaust
he is a monument in german literary
history and at the same time
he is a sad ashamed terrified part of us
all kafka once wrote that the task of
literature
is to reconnect us with feelings that
might otherwise be
unbearable to study but which
desperately need our attention
a book must he wrote be the axe for the
frozen
sea within us his books were among the
most touching
frightening and accurate axes ever
written
you